Hello and welcome to Python Bytes.
We deliver Python news and headlines directly to your earbuds.
This is episode 396, recorded August 13, 2024.
I'm Michael Kennedy.
And I'm Brian Okken.
And this episode is brought to you by Scout APM.
Thank you to Scout for their continued support of the show.
Check out their link in the show notes.
We'll tell you more about them later.
If you want to follow us on the socials, you can find us all over on Mastodon.
Links at the top of the show notes.
And we are on X, although less active than we are on Mastodon, I would say.
We're going to catch the live show.
You can do that at pythonbytes.fm/live.
And it takes you either to the old ones or lets you know about the new one if it's running right there.
So we appreciate when people are there, but audio always, always works as well.
Brian, how are you doing?
I'm good.
Yeah?
I didn't know we were still on X.
But...
Well...
You're on X.
Here's the thing.
You're not on X anymore, okay?
Did you actually delete your account?
I have an account, but I check it like every other month or something like that.
So...
I still get notifications if people will @ mention me.
Oh, okay.
I'll see it, but it's kind of the same thing.
I don't like drop in and cruise through there as much.
I'd be happy on Mastodon, but there's just, I would say 75% of the people that follow us,
interact with us, at least through the show account, probably didn't make the transition.
So...
Okay.
I should pay attention more.
So, apologies.
Still there for them.
Yeah.
We're still there for them.
Okay, good.
That's all I meant by it.
Okay.
All right.
Well, let's kick it off with your first item.
Okay.
I want to talk, I think I already, I covered UV, a UV article yesterday, or last week.
Yeah.
Well, it's the summertime and you got to be real careful about your UV index and put on your...
Oh, wait, no, not that.
I love UV.
Oh my God, we could put together a UV index.
It'd be like the...
That would be awesome.
Anyway, so I saw this article, Python packaging is great now, UV is all you need.
And I'm like, I don't know.
It seems like a little silver bullet dish for me.
But I took a look at it anyway.
This is from Juan Luis Cano Rodriguez, awesome name and cool profile picture.
Anyway, so UV, what is, we like to bash on packaging, but it's
just continually getting better.
And especially with people like Brett Cannon trying to continue to make it better, it's going
to, and people at UV, at Astral, making UV better.
But so what is this about?
This article, I didn't really want to completely cover the article, but there's some pretty cool
stuff here.
So bootstrapping, getting a project started is difficult sometimes, or knowing what to do.
And I've been using UV for making virtual environments, and it's really fast at that.
But I took another look at it.
There's been some updates that I didn't know it did some cool stuff.
So one of the highlights here is UV Python, it manages Python versions.
And I'm like, what?
It does what?
So I went and checked it out.
And you can, so you don't even have to.
So you can go down and say UV Python install, and it installs Python versions for you.
And it's really fast, but you don't have to.
And I'll tell you why in just a sec.
You can install it like that, but you can also say UV Python list, and it lists all the Python
versions that it can find on your system.
But if you say UV, V-E-N-V, so creating a virtual environment, you can give it a Python
flag with a number so you can do list ahead of time.
And it tells you not only what versions are there, but also what versions it has available.
So you can say, like, if you don't have 3.11 on your system, you can say 3.11 anyway, and
it'll install it.
I'm like, does that really work?
So I checked it out.
I tried it.
I personally, it said that it would just do it automatically if it wasn't there.
But I had to add the Python.
There's a flag called Python preference managed, and it's listed here somewhere.
Anyway, Python preference managed.
>> --Python preference.
And then you can say UV managed, only managed, or managed system, or only system.
Gotcha.
Awesome.
>> Yeah.
Yeah, Python preference.
But if you say managed, which is supposedly the default, but I had to pass it in anyway,
it just does it.
So I'm like, this is cool.
And I installed, like, six versions of Python on my Mac yesterday in seconds.
And just to have fun, to create virtual environments.
And it's just neat.
So I only really need a Python with -- I usually use Python within virtual environments.
So being able to just install one into a virtual environment is cool.
So what else can we do?
So there's other things that UV can do that, like, it can initialize PyProject.toml for you.
And it sets up -- if you do a net, it sets up PyProject.toml and a readme and a source layout.
It doesn't do a lot, but it gets you started.
The thing that I thought was neat is add.
So you can add dependencies to your PyProject.toml with UV add.
And so you don't have to look up the syntax for it.
The other cool thing about it is you can give it the dev flag.
You can say UV add --dev.
Like, you can say --dev pytest, and it'll add pytest to your development dependencies,
which is neat.
So I guess I was going to say packaging is not solved with UV, but maybe it is.
There's some pretty cool stuff.
>> This is awesome, yeah.
If you look up -- if you say UV help, there's a whole bunch of experimental items through here.
So there's run, init, add.
A lot of these are experimental features.
Tree is cool.
You can do a project dependency tree using UV.
So there's a lot of stuff that I used to use other tools for that UV's doing.
So kind of cool.
Locking, creating lock files.
>> I like the self.
I like it.
>> What does self do?
>> Manage the UV executable itself.
>> Oh, yeah.
Okay.
>> So there was a lot of drama, honestly, not on our show, but on the mailing lists
when this was announced.
>> With UV Python?
>> No, with UV pip.
>> UV pip, yeah.
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And so the reason that Charlie and team chose UV pip as part of the CLI interface as a subcommand
was so that they had space to do all these other things.
If you just said UV install, well, is that install the Python thing?
Is that install a package?
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Right?
And so they put that in there as almost like a namespace for all their commands and stuff.
And how much new stuff is under these experimental sections, starting to feel like, okay, this
is what I had in mind, right?
>> Yeah.
Yeah.
So the experimental part makes me nervous to put it into my normal everyday workflow a
little bit.
But for personal workflow stuff, why not play with it?
>> Yeah.
>> So.
>> You know, as you're going through this and seeing this title, Python packaging is
great.
UV is all you need.
I think it's all I use these days.
I don't think I use anything else.
>> There are some systems that the whole, especially with certain firewalls that I know
you can get around it with UV, but there are some systems that I work on where I have trouble
working with UV, but pip works fine.
So.
>> Oh, interesting.
Okay.
Yeah.
I have basically three or four, maybe four or five aliases that are just like two or
three letters that will do all the combining, you know, like the full commands with this
and that.
So those used to be pip commands.
Now they're UV pip with like the different parameters and stuff.
>> Yeah.
And I tried, so when UV pip started, came, I tried to alias pip to UV pip and same with
virtual environment.
But I realized that I kind of like control.
I like to be able to use both.
So I just sort of taught myself these UV commands.
>> Yeah.
Yeah.
Sounds good.
Not too hard, is it?
All right.
Well, I have a set of bookends around Python versions to start and end the show here.
So let's start with Python 3.12.5 was out just last week, came out right after the show
was released, I think.
So we didn't cover it, but yeah, here we have a brand new version of the most recent version
Python.
And I just checked by the way.
>> What?
>> Yeah.
And I just checked with the UV Python list and I think 3.12.4 is the latest there, just
to give you a sense that like one week into it, apparently we don't have the latest.
I was kind of hoping like that thing would be super cutting edge on top of it.
So, but I wonder if I, you know what, it's possible that my UV is over a week out of
date and it doesn't know, right?
Something like that.
I don't know.
Anyway, 3.12.5 is out.
And if you scroll through, I'm linking to the release notes.
Sometimes it's hard to find like what is actually changed in say 3.12.4 to 3.12.5, because if
you go to the, if you go to python.org and click on downloads, a lot of times it'll just
show like, well, here's what's new for 3.12.
Be like, great.
And from the last one that I had, the last one was that.
But if you go, you can find the release notes at which I'm linking to.
And so there are a lot of releases and changes in just this minor point release.
So we've got a bunch of tests that are fixed.
How about that, Brian?
That's great.
Yeah.
Two different security improvements, patches, I guess.
You know, they're not, don't think they have CVEs.
So there must not be too bad.
Like audit, like missing audit events around certain behaviors.
Like, okay, so you couldn't audit it properly, but it's not, it's not a, you know, all your
bases are belong to us sort of thing.
Bunch of stuff in the library.
So for example, a new version of pip.
So for just a moment, just briefly, when you create a virtual environment, I won't say
your pip is out of date.
But this, things like this, fix crash when importing SSL after the main interpreter starts.
Hmm, might want to have that not happen.
Handle value errors raised by os.stat.
Fix some error messages in pickle.
Here's one that's worth paying attention to.
Fixed a seg fault in asyncio.task.getCoroutine.
Okay.
You know, a lot of times you think of, at least I think one of the really huge advantages
of Python is when stuff goes wrong, your program doesn't just go poof and go away.
It, it reports the error.
It gives you a chance to catch it, right?
You like this, Python itself doesn't die.
It knows it's something's gone terribly wrong and it shuts down.
Right.
But Python, CPython seg faults, then it just goes poof and goes away.
So there's a ton of stuff like this.
So I just wanted to call, call people's attention to all the changes here.
And there's even some that look like performance.
For example, what was it?
f-strings.
If you have an F string that has just one entry into it, it, I think it used to create
an abstract syntax tree to try to build it up.
And they're like, ah, not really needed all that stuff for a single F string.
Our F string was single entry in it.
So, yeah, that's, that's going to be a nice performance improvement as well.
Instead of dash, how do they F string it?
Yeah.
So anyway, these are all good things.
Yeah, definitely.
f-strings are getting, getting more secure, more fast, more faster, better.
Faster, better, stronger.
We have the technology, we can rebuild it.
Okay.
Can you even imagine going back to the time before f-strings?
It was a dark time.
My percent, my percent key still has no, no characters on it.
No, just kidding.
Yeah.
Yeah, indeed.
Okay.
And before we go on to the next one, you were probably going to give us some really
awesome segue there, but let's talk about, ScoutAPM before we move on.
Okay.
Let me tell you real quick about ScoutAPM.
They're big supporters of Python Bytes.
So we appreciate that very much.
So if you are tired of spending hours trying to find the root cause of issues impacting
your performance, then you owe it to yourself to check out ScoutAPM.
They're a leading Python application performance monitoring tool, APM, that
helps you identify and solve performance abnormalities faster and easier.
ScoutAPM ties bottlenecks such as memory leaks, slow database queries, background
jobs, and the dreaded N plus one queries that you can end up if you do lazy loading
in your ORM, then you say, Oh no, why is it so slow?
Why are you doing 200 database queries for what should be one?
So you can find out things like that.
And it links it back directly to the source code.
So you can spend less time in the debugger and healing logs and just finding the
problems and moving on.
And you'll love it because it's built for developers by developers.
It makes it easy to get set up.
Seriously, you can do it in less than four minutes.
So that's awesome.
And the best part is the pricing is straightforward.
You only pay for the data that used with no hidden overage fees or per seat pricing.
And I just learned this, Brian.
They also have, they provide the pro version for free to all open source projects.
So if you're an open source maintainer and you want to have ScoutAPM for that project,
just shoot them a message or something on their pricing page about that.
So you can start your free trial and get instant insights today.
Visit pythonbytes.fm/scout.
The link is in your podcast player show notes as well.
And please use that link.
Don't just search for them because otherwise they don't think you came from us.
And then they'd stop supporting the show.
So please use our link pythonbytes.fm/scout.
Check them out.
It really supports the show.
Over to you, Brian.
Alrighty.
I want to talk about talks a little bit.
We haven't talked, actually brought up talks for a while, I don't think.
But there's an article on Victor Remark, Victor Remark's blog,
about compile and use dependencies for multiple Python versions with talks.
And it's kind of a neat idea.
I use talks for incorporating it with GitHub actions a lot to be able to,
well, and just locally to be able to test multiple Python versions
and multiple versions of different libraries, how they work together.
Talks is great for things like that.
But one of the things that I didn't think about was doing pinning,
like compiling pinned list or lock lists for dependencies for multiple Python versions.
And so this article walks you through kind of why you would want to do that,
but then also how to.
And the little trick here, which I think is cool,
is that talks uses an environment name called the env name.
And so there is a way to be able to specify,
use that to look at different, the talks environment that it created,
because it creates a little virtual environments when it's running.
But the neat thing about that is you can use it other places.
And the idea around this was to go ahead and use,
this article uses pip tools, but really I think you could use anything,
but to target a compile like a pip tools compile and send it to,
it's using pip compile and using pyproject.toml as the base file,
and then outputting to a requirements env name, which is,
or a env.text or a, like a env-dev.text.
So you could do like a requirements with a requirements file,
essentially with your environment specified in it.
You could, in this example, it's using a directory,
pumping them all into a requirements folder with a directory,
but you could also do a directory.
And then also, I also like to have a requirements-whatever.
So even if I had them all filed into a directory,
I usually put something like requirements-312.text
or something like that.
But having that, be able to specify it from the project,
allows the little trick to be able to say,
oh, here's an example of with the requirements-,
I like that a little bit better.
But to have a requirements target within talks,
so that you can use that to compile your project,
compile those and while they're running,
instead of like in CI or something could grab those.
And instead of generating a, just whatever it can find,
it's a pinned or a locked set of dependencies.
It might be a little bit more consistent.
So, so that locally, the, and the idea would be then,
locally, you, when you're testing yourself,
you can say, hey, I'm ready to update my dependencies.
And then it regenerate the, all of the,
all of the dev files and then, or all the lock files.
And then later, when you're, when CI is running,
it doesn't look up dependencies.
It just like knows the fixed links or the fixed versions.
So kind of a neat idea.
I wanted to highlight that.
I also wanted to highlight this because I wanna,
I like this idea, but I wanna do it with UV.
And I wanna, I'd like to be, I think I'll play with this,
but if anybody else has time to play with this
and see if they can get it working with UV,
I'd love to see the outcome.
So, yeah, that's awesome.
I imagine you can, because if it was using pip-tools,
you know, it's got the pip compile behaviors.
It shouldn't be that hard.
Yeah, yeah, it's awesome.
Yeah, this looks great.
I love it.
What do you got for us?
You, let's, let's close it out with, I think dark.
I did tell you it was the 13th, didn't I?
Yeah.
So I present to you a, this is not exactly a Python thing,
but I feel like this is anyone who builds web apps
or other types of apps and interacts with,
you know, users sort of thing.
So super set, if you will.
I present to you a catalog of dark patterns for software.
Says, discover a variety of dark pattern examples
sorted by category to help you better understand
deceptive design practices.
So there's some that you probably would know
like bait and switch.
And each one of these has at least one concrete,
like case study of evil, badness of darkness, let's say.
So the bait and switch one, which says this tactic lures users
with an enticing offer only to change the terms unexpectedly.
So they've got a lift 60% off.
Wouldn't you like 60% off of your next ride?
Just click here and sign up, right?
And then once, actually your next two ride
that says right here.
Yeah.
But then actually, as you try to apply it,
it turns out it only counts towards 60%
off the first $10.
So if you like went to the airport, it was 50 bucks.
It's like, well, you know, it's still 44.
Yeah, perfect.
So that's not ideal.
To me, the classic bait and switch is the cable companies
for internet or anything.
Like, don't you want to add like a home phone,
like digital phone?
And then you can add like the sports package
and it's only $5 more for the first, you know,
for the first six months.
And then it's like $150 more.
So I had one just like yesterday.
I had an email from my cell phone provider that said,
since you've been here, like so many numbers of years,
we're going to give you 10% off.
I'm like, that's cool.
And I clicked on it and it was 10% off
any of your case purchases.
(laughing)
So shady.
So that, I mean, people probably know that one,
but there's other ones that are interesting.
Like one that I really like is the Roach Motel.
Okay.
So what is that?
Oh, it's this dark pattern usually used for subscriptions,
making it easy to sign up, but nearly impossible to cancel.
So there's, you know, you can't,
there's not like a just unsubscribe us button.
You've got to call somebody
and they try to talk you out of it.
Like I'm a hat tip the cable companies again on this.
Right.
But yeah.
One click subscribe.
But if you want to, if you want to cancel,
please come down to our office during hours of four and three.
Exactly.
And if you don't get through the line of people backed up,
trying to get out of it, then you'll, you'll do bad.
Try again the next week.
So there's a bunch of these.
I'll do one more.
Just the people can go play with them.
Disguised ads.
Oh, I thought it was disgusting ads.
Okay.
Disguised ads, which are themselves disgusting,
but the pattern is disguised.
So Microsoft edge, for example,
and I feel like Google, this is towards Google Chrome,
like a thing towards,
I feel like it's also kind of reverse a lot of like,
Google does that as well.
Like, wouldn't you rather use this instead
when you search for something?
Anyway, I'll give you the example that's on the page.
So you may encounter not one, but two dark padding patterns
when attempting to get Google Chrome onto your computer.
When you have Microsoft edge,
this happens when you have a empty install of windows,
you have edge installed, but not Chrome.
And, or, I mean, I feel like installing Chrome itself
as a dark pattern that you should just avoid.
Use of all the brave Firefox, something else.
But anyway, that's not the point.
There's two here.
And the first one is disguised ads.
The second one is confirm shaming.
And so this is like a good case here.
So if you go over to google.com/chrome in edge
and you go to the, you go to the,
like the, where you get to download it,
it literally has a built into the browser pop-up
that comes out of the menu bar.
You know, that dress bar rather says,
I hate saving money, said no one ever.
Microsoft edge is the best browser for online shopping.
(laughing)
Just by literally visiting the Chrome page,
you get this pop-up that's like integrated,
not into the HTML, but into the UI of the browser.
- That's so funny.
- Yeah, so that's, that's shady.
That's one.
- I kind of love the boldness of that though, actually.
(laughing)
- I know.
And then if you go to, go to Bing, I believe this,
which is the default search engine,
and you just search for Chrome, you get some results.
But then there's like this other part.
Oh no, this is actually in the start, the start menu.
This is in the start menu.
So if you type Chrome, you're like trying to run Chrome.
(laughing)
Half of the whole start menu says, try Bing wallpaper.
Switch to the browser recommended by Microsoft.
Default edge.
- Dude, that's rough.
Yeah, so what's cool is that it says, look,
here like it kind of highlights the various patterns
that are here and then like other companies
that do similar patterns.
Anyway, I think this is interesting reading.
I think figuring out, like just being aware of this stuff.
So if you're involved in building these things,
you're like, hey guys, people are gonna not like us.
Could we do this a little bit differently?
You know, sometimes marketing will win.
Sometimes developers will win.
- So are these dark patterns or maybe growth hacking?
- Yes, is this our yacht or is this a dark pattern?
Could it be both?
- What could I incorporate these into?
No.
- Yeah, it's like, #EUWin if you can get like all dark patterns.
- Oh, that'd be fun to try to.
- It'd be a good growth hack
'cause then you could appear under every category.
It'd be like some like link.
- Pre-advertising.
- Exactly, yeah.
Anyway, this is what I got for you.
Kind of interesting.
- Nice.
- Extras, you got any extras you wanna share?
- The extra I wanted to shout out was just,
I think I have my recording done for Hellopytest.
The only thing left to record is the summary at the end.
There's a few things I wanna,
like one extra video I wanna record,
but I wanna edit everything first.
So I'm in the process of editing
and keeping track of everything
so that at the end I can go,
"Hey, we went through all these things."
So I wanna make sure.
Actually, the thing that I have left is
I want to review all of the command line flags
that I use in the course,
but I don't remember all the ones I've used.
So I'm writing down as I'm editing.
- Nice, that's awesome.
- But I'm on track for August 19th.
A few people have ordered already.
Thank you so much, everyone that's ordered so far.
So love you.
My wife loves you.
We went out to get coffee off of money we got from this.
- Beautiful.
Yeah, available for pre-order now.
- Yeah.
What you got?
- I have just a couple things.
Django 5.1 released.
So big deal here is easier guardrails for authentication
'cause having people access stuff
that was supposed to be authenticated,
but isn't is bad.
They didn't say that, that's my words.
The new and shiny login required middleware
is available which enforces authentication for all views.
Better screen reader support, better HTML semantics.
The second oldest ticket is now fixed
with a long awaited query string template tag.
So these things are all good.
And let's see, what's there?
Yeah, I thought there might've been a CVE
or something in here, but I don't think so.
I saw Django CVE not too long ago, security deal,
but it doesn't seem like it's addressed with this one.
So it must've been fixed previously.
All right, so that, and then here's the bookend.
We started with 3.12.5 being available.
Well, how about Python 3.13 looking forward
with release candidate one is out.
So this happened a little bit ago,
but if you're out there and they say,
"Please test, you have a package,
especially a popular one,
please test it with Python 3.13 ahead of time
so we can do stuff about it."
And you're like, "Oh, it's betas.
I'm not gonna take the trouble.
I'm not gonna worry about it."
Well, it's now officially stable in terms of features, right?
They're not gonna add or remove things ideally
unless they absolutely have to.
So you should be able to properly start putting energy
into testing and playing with this one.
And this one is a big deal
because this is the first free threaded Python,
which is gonna have significant effects
on runtime behavior, not just the API still work, right?
So it's gonna be worth testing with this one.
- All those other versions of Python
you have to pay for threading.
This one's free threading.
- Yeah, it's awesome.
Finally, it's free.
You just have, yeah, you have to pay by buying other machines
and running copies on them to get parallels.
- No, so I was hoping that UV Python
would have 3.13 there, but it doesn't yet.
So we'll just- - Yeah, that would,
all right, UV team out there listening.
- Just Astro, come on Astro, what are you doing?
- Exactly, let's turn UV Python into like,
this is how I get the freshest Python,
which is actually one of the things that's a little tricky.
Like homebrew, it takes a week for that stuff to show up
and other stuff, yeah.
- A week?
Yeah, who wants week old coffee?
- No, no, your threads are totally stale by now.
(both laughing)
- It's a goofy episode, man.
- It is, all right.
I know you got the joke for us this week, so take us out.
- Well, actually, before we get onto this,
I was just thinking, because you,
when you were talking about Django,
I thought of a new, of a dorky joke.
So what do you call a 17 year old insect?
A minor bug?
- Oh, that's pretty good.
- Okay, so I saw this Ars Technica, is it Ars or A-R-S?
I don't know, Ars Technica?
- I say Ars, but I know now you say that,
I'm not sure I've ever heard anyone pronounce it.
So go with Ars, 'cause it's lowercase.
- Ars Technica, had an article,
"Parody site Clownstrike refuses to bow down
"to Cloudstrike's bogus DMCA takedown."
So there's an article here, I wanted to check it out myself.
So if you go to clownstrike.lol, and we'll refresh it.
See if it, it starts out looking like Crowdstrike,
but it has a little goofy hat on it.
And then if you, I'm not gonna play the music now,
but if you play music, it's got like some goofy little music
that goes along with it, and there's a clown.
That's it, it's just funny.
But now if you click on the left,
it tells you about all this,
well, it tells you the Ars Technica article,
but it also talks about this story
about how they had these takedown,
Crowdstrike tried to take them down,
and it's just silly.
There's some other stuff here too
that I think is just hilarious.
Like the, what, scam advisor lists clownstrike.lol
as a highly trusted, might be safe.
It's like nothing there,
except for just this goofy little picture.
But there are some other stuff in it.
You can read the whole story and all the letters about,
or all the emails back and forth about the takedowns.
And actually, I was surprised to find out
that they had to, like Cloudflare was hosting this,
but it like accepted the takedown at first,
and eventually backed down,
but even after, but after it got moved.
But I'm surprised that it got taken down so fast
because obviously this is a parody site,
and parody is protected.
There's no way, like even a cursory look at this,
anybody would think this is a realistic violation.
Yeah, it's not trying to impersonate it
or anything like that, for sure.
No, just making fun of the situation.
And I think that they just probably,
I mean, they really should have just ignored it
because now clownstrike is known,
and we're talking about it,
and Ars Technic is talking about it, anyway.
Exactly.
It's the Barbra Streisand effect, right?
Yeah.
So.
Oh boy.
Anyway.
Yeah, I'm somewhat sympathetic to CrowdStrike,
but this is a bad look.
You know, if you've got to write native code
that runs in the kernel,
I think the smallest mistake,
and it has to be like updated within hours
of you learning new information,
I don't know.
It's tough.
Apparently it's one of the best antivirus systems out there
that actually works and isn't just,
you know, you want to talk dark patterns,
like a lot of this antivirus,
clean your computer stuff is really shady.
But boy, did they cause a problem,
and I would not want to be in their shoes.
No.
Well, I don't know.
I mean, a couple of weeks of shame
over you get billions of dollars to pay for that shame.
So.
Yeah, I think they're going to get a lot of lawsuits
from a lot of angry Fortune 500 companies.
And even if they win,
defending them is going to hurt them bad.
If it doesn't kill them, it's going to hurt them bad.
So.
Okay.
Yeah.
Sympathies out there for somebody?
Some.
A little bit.
But I feel like they've certainly earned this website.
And wow, I didn't know LOL was the top level domain.
Yeah.
It's funny.
It makes me laugh.
Yeah, it makes me laugh.
I wonder what that stands, what it is.
Is it like a country or something?
Is it literally LOL?
Like laugh out loud?
Or is it because they're like .pizza is the top level domain as well,
which just seems wrong.
Oh, that does seem wrong.
Really?
I think so.
I'll have to check that out.
Like pepperoni.pizza and like, you know, Hawaiian.
Honestly.
Yeah.
Pineapple.
Maybe we need to get some domains.
Yeah.
Anyway.
Okay.
Awesome.
Thanks for sharing.
This is great.
All right.
Thanks for being here.
Like always.
Thank you.
Bye.